okay here's the well the title slide I
sense this year happen to be 2020 and
that means clear vision I thought I'd
get that into the title of this these
slides and then you've seen in these six
pieces as a sort of look ahead and I'm
gonna start on that first piece a equals
CR that's the new way I like to start
teaching linear algebra and I'll tell
you why okay oh here we have a few
examples well that will lead to our
ideas you see that matrix a zero a
matrix is just a square or rectangle of
numbers and but those are those numbers
have special features if you look
closely well you see 1 3 2 as row 1 and
then what do you see for Row 3 2 6 4 and
there's like those are - those are two
vectors in the same direction why is
that because 2 6 4 is exactly 2 times 1
3 2 and in the middle there is 4 times 1
3 2 so I have 3 rows in the same
direction and actually also this is the
MAGIX can I tell you this right at the
start their columns look at the columns
1 for 2 if I multiply that by 3 I get 3
12 6 if I multiply it by 2 I get 2 8 4
so sometimes somehow magically the
columns are in the same direction
exactly when the rows are in the same
direction they're different
that's what linear algebra is about the
relations between columns and rows okay
and here well here's another one I'll
look at there again you see rho1 plus
rho2 equal Row 3 so it's not quite like
this where every row was a was in the
same direction but here's if I add rows
1 & 2 I get Row 3 so that's a matrix of
- we'll say you'll see it okay then here
s is for symmetric matrices though those
are the kings of linear algebra and here
are a few small samples and the queens
of linear algebra are these matrices I
call Q those are called orthogonal
matrices orthogonal meaning
perpendicular so there's and they tend
to express a rotation so that's a
rotation matrix and orthogonal matrix
that rotates the plane and there's a
pretty general matrix that we'll see at
the very end okay so I'm into the start
of the column space so that's a word I
don't use in the videos for quite a
while but here you see I'm using it in
the first minutes so I look at a matrix
well first let's just remember how to
multiply a matrix by a vector okay there
is a matrix a there's a vector X with
three components and the way I like to
multiply them is to take the columns of
a that's what I'm focusing on columns of
a there they are 1 2 & 3 I multiply them
by those three numbers X 1 X 2 X 3 and I
add and that's called a linear
combination linear because nothing is
squared or cubed or anything and
combination because I'm putting them
together adding them together okay so
that's the idea and now the big idea is
in that top line I want to think of all
combinations so this is one particular
combination with a particular X 1 and X
2 and X 3 but now I let every I think of
every X 1 and X 2 and X 3 all the
vectors that I could get well of course
I could get the first column by taking 1
+ 0 + 0 that would give me the first
column but it's really mixtures of the
columns that this produces and it fills
out it fills out in this case a whole
plane in three dimensions
these vectors have three components were
in three dimensions and can you just
imagine in your head two lines meeting
at zero zero zero so they they cross but
I just have two lines and now I take I
fill in between those lines so it's
filling in between those two lines is
taking the linear combinations that's
where they are and the result is I get a
plane I do not get the whole space
because nothing is going in a third
direction for this matrix all right so
let's see more about this so that's that
word column space and I use the capital
C for that and it's all the vectors I
can get that way all the combinations of
the columns and now I ask oh oh and me I
just answered this question sorry I
asked is the column space all the
combinations is that the whole 3d space
which everybody calls r3 for real three
or is it a plane or is it just a line
well the answer is plane it probably
even gives us the answer that's a good
thing about this subject the answer is a
plane because I have two different lines
that meet at the zero and when I fill in
between them I have a flat plane I don't
go in the third Direction good so that's
the column space for this matrix and I
and and and and here's a little more
saying about that we kept column 1 and
we kept column 2 because you remember
those two columns the first two were
different they went in different
directions they go in different
direction we did not keep the third
column because it was just a sum of the
first two it's on the plane nothing new
so if so the real meat of the matrix a
is in the column matrix see that has
just the two columns and what about our
because this is my plan for the
first few weeks first two to three weeks
of linear algebra is is to understand so
that five five three would be called a
dependent vector because it depends on
the first two those were independent so
those are the two that I keep in the
matrix C and then that matrix R oh well
I know I'm multiplying two matrices and
you know how to do that but I always
have another way to look at it so the
way I look at it is my linear
combinations you remember those so
multiplying is a combination of these
guys first I have one of the first
column that's my first column the next
time I have one of the second column
that's my second vector and the third
one is this guy one of that and one of
that so these two are the independent
ones and that's dependent and then a
full set of independent ones that's
called a basis really fundamental so I
guess I think that the linear algebra
should just start with these key ideas
just go with them and we learned
something it almost falls in our laps
it's a great first great and not obvious
fact about linear algebra I'm just
amazed to have it here the number of
independent columns in a which it was
two is equal to the number of
independent rows in are also two you
remember that we had two rows and two
columns so two two two columns first in
C two rows and our and the point is that
that's telling us and we just checked
that those two rows were into two
columns were independent the two rows
are independent they're the basis and
then we learned that the column space
has dimension to R equals two for this
example and the row space
has the same dimension so the rank is a
column rank R equals the row rank R it's
like you know if you had a 50 by 80
matrix okay that's 4,000 numbers you
couldn't see what those these dimensions
are but linear algebra is telling you
the dimension of the row space and the
column space 50 of 1 and 80 and another
are equal okay so this is again coming
early and we'll see it again but but
it's good to start linear algebra from
day one and then here's another great
fact about equations because matrices
lead to a lead to equations where X is
the unknown and this equation has zero
on the right-hand sides so you how could
we get 0 on the right-hand side we could
take one of that and let me change that
to a minus sign and that to a minus sign
one of those minus one of those minus
one of those would be zero zero zero so
that one and minus one and minus one
would tell us an X and that's the
solution we're in applying linear
algebra and engineering in physics in in
economics in business you end up with
equations things balance and you want to
know how many solutions there are and
linear algebra is created to answer that
question okay so now I'm just going to
say a little more about this starting
method of the course oh I want to focus
here on these interesting method
interesting matrices where every column
is a multiple of the first column every
Row is a multiple of the first row the
instead of having two independent
columns and rows these matrices have
only one so then C has one column and R
has one row and the rank is one these
are the building blocks of linear
algebra
these rank one matrices column times row
the previous matrix would would have one
of those blocks and a second block a big
matrix from data science would have
hundreds of blocks but great theorem in
linear in linear algebra is to break
that big matrix into these simple pieces
so that's the goal for the end of the
course okay and finally a last thought
about these so this is C times R I'm
urging teachers to present that part at
the early so what are the good things
I've marked with a plus first of all the
the columns we're looking at them in C
in and we see them from a we take them
directly from a our turns out to be a
famous matrix row reduced echelon form
it's called so to see that pop up here
is terrific and then this wonderful fact
that row rank equal column rank is clear
from this C times R so those are all
terrifically good things the other thing
I have to say is that c and r are not
great for avoiding roundoff for being
good in large computations this is a
first
factorization but not the best one for
computing for big computing right so
that's ill-conditioned means could
they're difficult to deal with and also
we often have a matrix with all the
columns are independent and it's a
square matrix all the columns are
independent we can solve ax equal B all
the time but then then if all the
columns are independent then our matrix
C is just the same as a we didn't get
anywhere an R would be the identity
matrix like a 1 because a equals C so
so this is the starting point picking
out the independent columns but not the
end of course and I'll stop here and
pick up on the next factorization right
away Thanks